là j'ouvre notre notre second thème
débat de société sur le port de
l'uniforme à l'école le rassemblement
national l'inscrit dans les propositions
qu'il fera le 12 janvier dans ce qu'on
appelle sa niche parlementaire les
candidats à la présidence LR y sont
favorables des députés macronistes
préparent eux aussi une loi dans ce sens
s un bon outil de défense de la laïcité
de lutte contre le harcèlement avant
d'entendre nos experts je vous propose
un reportage dans une école privée de
Compiègne depuis 2018 les enfants du
primaire y portent une blouse et c'est
une tenue scolaire qui s'impose à partir
du collège Audrey Vittaz
c'est au moment de la récréation que les
choses sautent aux yeux la cour de
l'établissement privé Sévigné devient
quasiment monochrome de la parka à la
polaire en passant par le sac et le
bonnet tout est au couleur de ses vignes
ici on ne parle pas d'uniforme trop
militaire mais de tenue Zoltan est en 6e
il porte celle des jours importants
bleu marine et par dessus on peut mettre
le pull col V ou la polaire pourquoi pas
et par dessus c'est encore on a plus
froid on peut mettre la parka il faut
compter une centaine d'euros de tenues
pour 4 ans d'études et elle est
obligatoire du collège à la terminale
pour que le vêtement ne soit plus un
sujet et cela fonctionne au début
j'étais un peu contre parce que je me
disais que ça allait être plus gênant
qu'on pouvait pas s'habiller comme on
voulait mais finalement on s'y habitue
il y a pas de prise de tête le matin
c'est assez
ça nous permet de nous reconnaître avec
l'établissement on sait d'où on vient
pour voir ce se mettre en valeur par
rapport à nos qualités non pas se
comporte
[Applaudissements]
Eric Ducros le chef d'établissement
s'avoure il me croise ils me disent
bonjour et ça fait partie de la tenue de
dire bonjour c'est pas moi qui leur dit
il faut me dire bonjour mais quand il
l'a mise en place en 2018 il a eu
quelques doutes je me suis dit comment
ça va se passer s'il y a s'il y a des
familles qui arrivent à la porte et qui
dit ben non on veut pas et on il faut
qu'il rentre quand même etc j'ai mal
dormi la nuit de la rentrée seul de
famille ont finalement quitté
l'institution il faut dire qu'Eric
Ducroc travaille sur ce projet depuis
plus de 10 ans il a d'abord expliqué et
réexpliquer la raison de la tenue le
vêtement c'est un objet de séduction
un moyen de provocation et une source de
prosélytisme le vêtement se retrouve au
centre de l'école et on a d'autres
choses à gérer que le vêtement il a
ensuite fait les choses progressivement
avec la blouse chez les plus petits en
2004 ce recul le rang critique vis-à-vis
des politiques qui veulent instaurer
l'uniforme pour lutter uniquement contre
les signes ostentatoires à l'école la
tenue à l'école dépasse le critère
religieux et d'ailleurs si on le traite
comme ça on va braquer les jeunes on va
les braquer et on va plus encore les
stigmatiser d'après lui l'uniforme ou la
tenue ne s'impose pas par la loi pour le
faire accepter il faut travailler
longtemps avec les élèves et leurs
parents
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce second débat Jacques gros
Perrin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur LR du Doux doctor en lettres de
sciences de l'éducation et membre de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication Louise Touré
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
productrice de l'émission être et savoir
sur France Culture Jean Rémy Girard
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi président
du Syndicat national des lycées et
collèges il me manque école aussi
j'étais en train de me dire qu'il en
manquait un même le supérieur
politique est resté à mes côtés
évidemment tiens un sondage pour
commencer alors il est un peu ancien on
n'a pas trouvé de plus récent septembre
2020 63% des Français favorables à
l'uniforme à l'école voilà il vaut ce
qu'il vaut il date de septembre 2020
Jacques gros Perrin vous êtes favorable
à cette idée d'une tenue scolaire
obligatoire vous parlez pas d'uniforme
pourquoi oui parce que dès l'instant on
parle d'uniforme en caricature un petit
peu les établissements et les enfants
est la vie la vie des élèves je trouve
que la tenue d'établissement est une
scolaire ou une établissement on l'a
entendu dans le reportage c'est une
appartenance à une école à une équipe
regarder ce qui se passe dans les
quartiers les enfants ils ont une
certaine tenue ils se reconnaissent à
travers leur tenue dans différents types
de quartiers dans différentes types
d'espace chacun sa donne une
appartenance sociale et je trouve que la
tenue d'établissement c'est aussi dire
je rentre à l'école ça peut être une
tenue de travail parce qu'on travaille à
l'école et on se met dans un habit qui
nous met en prédisposition pour
travailler ça nous permet aussi de de
concourir en tout cas de porter
l'esprit de l'école l'ambiance de
l'école la fierté d'être dans cette
école là et puis au delà de supprimer en
tout cas des d'effacer les signes
ostensibles je crois que ça roule
surtout de de faire corps de faire
nation d'être autour d'un projet alors
on va ça pose quand même pas mal des
thèmes on va évidemment parler de
laïcité on va parler de harcèlement
aussi dans dans ce débat si on fait un
peu on l'a vu là dans une école privée à
Compiègne il y a eu aussi une expérience
à Provin et on verra des
on en parlera il y a aussi les Antilles
c'est ça il y a déjà des des lieux où
les enfants les élèves portent des
tenues scolaires oui oui mais ça peut
être aux Antilles ça peut être un
uniforme avec une jupe ou
juste un t-shirt avec le logo
d'établissement
ce que je trouve intéressant à poser
comme question c'est finalement si on
distingue les établissements les uns des
autres ça pose quand même
le problème de la non-mixité sociale qui
est une question en ce moment même
soulevée par le ministre de l'Éducation
et qui revient très souvent c'est un peu
un marronnier comme l'uniforme qui est
une réalité française la non mixité
sociale de plein d'établissements parce
que quartier c'est grégé parce que aussi
établissement éviter donc si on
distingue les enfants par leur école et
qu'on peut les repérer à leur tenue moi
je me demande parce qu'on leur met la
même tenue que la que la mixité enfin
l'absence de mixité va disparaître
suivant les établissements ça va encore
plus marquer les différences
d'établissements j'entends cet argument
j'aurais mis Girard qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce débat alors nous les
collègues sont moquent assez fortement
en fait de cette question de l'uniforme
c'est pas du tout une priorité
aujourd'hui enfin on est quand même dans
un état de l'éducation nationale qui est
pas très bon voilà difficulté de
recrutement
difficulté parfois à gérer les classes
nombre d'élèves importants dans les
classes difficultés à gérer les
coloclusive il y a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est plusieurs fois
des débats sur ces thèmes là avant de
venir à la question donc vous le savez
et effectivement l'uniforme c'est
vraiment très très très très loin dans
les priorités des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale il y en a qui
peuvent être pour il y en a qui peuvent
être contre mais
c'est enfin nous ce qui nous remonte
c'est on a tellement d'autres choses à
faire qu'est-ce qu'on va aller s'embêter
à ce laxer dans l'uniforme partout en
France ça va être d'une complexité ça
c'est la remontée de terrain et c'est
important de l'avoir après qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que vous vous
dites pourquoi pas en fonction des lieux
des établissements des demandes d'un
proviseur ou parfois d'un élu d'ailleurs
parce que ça vient ça vient aussi
souvent des élus est-ce qu'il faut le
généraliser est-ce qu'il faut accepter
que en fonction des lieux on puisse
l'autoriser c'est quoi votre position
alors nous on n'est pas du tout sur
l'idée qu'il faudrait l'imposer partout
dans le pays ça ça paraît vraiment une
fois encore très complexe il y a pas une
grosse tradition de l'uniforme de
manière globale en forme on n'a pas mise
à part justement ce qu'on disait dans et
encore même dans les Antilles c'est pas
partout voilà la blouse c'était pas un
uniforme c'était pas c'était pas là pour
ça une époque à l'école primaire donc
protéger les vêtements de l'encre voilà
c'est ça pour le dire plus simplement
j'allais dire si on était en train de
fabriquer un nouveau pays dans lequel on
met en place un nouveau système éducatif
avec des voilà ex nihilo on pourrait se
poser je pense tout à fait honnêtement
la question de l'uniforme là on est en
France le système éducatif il est déjà
assez installé allait s'embêter à
vouloir imposer cette idée là ça va
créer beaucoup plus de problèmes que ça
non que ça va votre réponse là-dessus et
peut-être aussi je rajoute une petite
critique qu'on entend souvent grosso
modo c'est un marqueur de la on va dire
de la droite conservatrice voilà
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça je n'ai
pas dit j'aurais pu très bien le dire au
départ je suis assez sénateur de droite
conservateur et pourtant non pourtant
non parce que je crois que les ce qui
fait la réussite dans les établissements
scolaires c'est l'établissement scolaire
c'est l'établissement scolaire qui est
la brique au départ vous allez dire où
les enseignants bien sûr mais
l'établissement scolaire qui fait
comment en donner on le voit nous
lorsqu'un enfant se sent bien dans un
établissement scolaire tout le reste
fonctionne bien les apprentissages les
savoirs fondamentaux les relations le
bien-être avec ses et ses camarades le
respect de son professeur etc c'est
l'ambiance de l'établissement qui rend
cela grâce aux anciens ambi bien sûr pas
simplement ça sinon au CPE chez
l'établissement etc et puis l'école
c'est pas une institution comme les
autres
lorsqu'on va à l'école on va à l'école
pour travailler elle est faite déjà de
mettre une tenue où chacun peut se
sentir fier d'appartenir à cet
établissement là c'est déjà les prémices
une première étape une première brique
pour mieux travailler oui mais pardon
nous interrompre vous répondez pas tout
à fait à jean-y Girard qui nous dit ça
va créer plus de difficultés que ça ne
va régler le problème non je crois que
c'est un débat qui peut être intéressant
c'est un débat qui est intéressant dans
la mesure où il y a des expérimentations
on l'a vu la surcompiègne il faut
laisser la liberté à chacun de le faire
il y a des établissements moi j'ai
appelé un chef d'établissement de Lyon
tout à l'heure il me parlait de cela et
c'est quelqu'un qui est plutôt moderne
si vous le permettez donc pas
conservateur plutôt progressiste et il
me dit moi dans mon établissement ça me
permettrait de d'éviter les problèmes de
mesurer les jupes ça me ça me
permettrait de pas perdre du temps à
regarder si ce sont
ostensible si c'est uniquement une
revendication religieuse si on n'a pas
une et on a d'autres choses à faire vous
avez raison on a d'autres choses à faire
donc simplement c'est une tenue chacun
fait le choix en tout cas fait le choix
dans le cadre du côté pédagogique etc
les élèves de leur avis donc vous vous
remettez l'argument laïcité s'attend
mais en fait la liberté elle existe déjà
c'est qu'on le voit à Compiègne ça
existe à province enfin c'est déjà
possible pour des pour des proviseurs de
décider de le faire ou des directeurs
d'établissements d'essayer de le faire
pas toujours c'est pas facile parce que
les parents et la résidence des parents
donc vous dit qu'il faut une loi moi
j'ai fait la loi peut être une étape
intéressante pour le faire moi je ferai
la loi je ferai surtout une
expérimentation d'accord je suis allé
visiter l'établissement de Sourdun cette
école
exceptionnelle où tous les enfants sont
des enfants qui viennent des cités
beaucoup de cités
dans cette internat d'excellence le
problème de la tenue scolaire ce n'est
pas un problème pour les élèves
leurs problèmes à eux c'est d'avoir des
bons états pour pouvoir accéder aux
meilleurs écoles aux meilleures
formations et il y avait un sentiment de
fierté à travers cela
ils vont attention etc et ça les met
dans des prix dispositions de
appartenant à l'établissement ça c'est
le plus c'est un argument important Luis
Suez je veux bien qu'on fasse un tout
petit peu d'histoire si vous l'avez dit
très rapidement tout à l'heure c'est pas
vraiment une tradition française c'est
ce que vous nous dites voir pas du tout
en fait l'uniforme a été très peu porté
en France dans certains lycées privés
parfois public comme des lycées d'élite
ou des lycées militaires uniforme à
Polytechnique par exemple alors qu'il
n'est pas un lycée évidemment mais ce
genre de tenue
de la Troisième République effectivement
il y a la blouse etc en blouse pas la
même pour pas se faire de taches d'encre
et des élèves c'est aussi une conquête
en fait pour les élèves de s'habiller
comme ils le souhaitaient après 68 on a
desséré un peu les cravates quand on
voit dans les films c'est marrant des il
y avait beaucoup moins de de garçons et
de filles qui allaient au lycée dans les
années 60 on les voit avec des tenues
très guindées ça a été une conquête de
pouvoir s'habiller de manière plus
confortable en survêtement en jean et je
ne me vois pas dire à des enfants
d'aujourd'hui mettez une cravate pour
aller en cours je trouve que enfin déjà
je non mais c'est l'exemple que nous a
montré c'était une certaine
je pense que je l'ai peut-être pas assez
développé
non plus hein
d'établissement privé où on a choisi
d'être là à porter par un projet
parental peut-être très spécifique c'est
pas l'école publique de toute façon être
fier d'appartenir à son établissement
quand on est dans un établissement dans
un quartier pauvre relégué et éviter par
les familles un peu plus riches je sais
pas où elle serait la fierté et je pense
pas que ça passerait
je voudrais qu'on parle évidemment vous
l'avez déjà évoqué mais on va vraiment
se concentrer sur la question de la
laïcité maintenant et de la défense de
la laïcité parce que c'est un argument
qui est souvent donné par ceux qui
proposent de revenir ou en tout cas
peut-être pas revenir puisque ça
n'existait pas massivement comme vous le
dites mais d'adopter une tenue scolaire
et pas forcément un uniforme je vous
rejoins dans le fait de dire plutôt
tenue scolaire tenez par exemple le
maire de Marignane on est dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône évidemment il est LR
Eric Le 17 il a écrit au ministre de
l'éducation nationale alors lui il
souhaite expérimenter deux mesures le
port d'uniforme alors c'est un petit
emploi lui et le lever de drapeau en
chantant la la Marseillaise l'argument
qui qui donne et on y vient inégalité
vestimentaire provocation vestimentaire
multiplication des fameuses à bayasses
et donc unique que certains jeux de Muse
balles portent méprises dans la laïcité
c'est des Dinant nos valeurs pardon je
vais trop vite nos valeurs je cite
Eric Le 17 pourquoi j'utilise ça parce
que je voudrais qu'on propose à Quentin
calmer de nous rejoindre tout de suite
pour voir ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
rebonsoir Quentin au Parlement puisque
le débat il est en train de revenir sur
le devant de la scène très clairement
avec cette question de la laïcité et
notamment des chiffres sur la hausse du
nombre d'atteintes à la laïcité à
l'école oui parce qu'ils ont été en
forte hausse le mois dernier au mois
d'octobre on a compté 720 signalements
contre 313 en septembre et 40 % de ses
attentes à la laïcité concernait le port
de tenue et de signe religieux les chefs
d'établissement sont parfois bien seuls
pour faire appliquer la loi notamment
face à des nouvelles tenues qui
s'appelle les abayas qu'on a vu dans les
lycées qui font l'objet de défi Tik Tok
etc et donc ça fait l'objet d'une
question au gouvernement c'était il y a
15 jours dans l'hémicycle écoutez un
extrait de ce qu'a dit un sénateur
monsieur le ministre ce que veulent les
enseignants c'est une réponse claire la
circulaire que vous avez donné de 9
novembre n'est pas clair alors
finalement quand je vous écoute
peut-être que la solution finalement
abaya ou pas ce serait peut-être de
porter l'uniforme pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
sénateur centriste Pierre-Antoine Lévy
c'est bien ça le gouvernement que
répondit à cela et bien en fait les
sénateurs ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils envoient des questions écrites
pour poser la question de ce retour de
l'uniforme ce retour effectivement année
écrit le ministère à une de ces
questions écrites la tenue vestimentaire
relève du règlement intérieur de chaque
école et établissement scolaire du
second degré la question de la
réglementation de la tenue vestimentaire
de par conséquent être discuté au sein
des établissements d'enseignement
scolaire et faire l'objet d'un consensus
local entre les membres de la communauté
éducative et donc également avec les
parents c'est donc ce qui avait écrit le
gouvernement c'était en 2013 et c'est
toujours dans ce cadre que doit se faire
une réflexion sur le sujet avait-il
ajouté cela ne relève pas d'une norme
nationale avec aucune ministère à
l'époque pourtant il y a régulièrement
on disait des parlementaires qui tentent
de légiférer sur ce sujet voilà on en
revient à cette idée d'appliquer une loi
nationale on a déjà vu trois
propositions de loi sur le sujet parmi
les dernières en date celles déposées en
2013 par Sophie joissin à l'époque
sénatrice de droite cette proposition de
live a été consignée par plusieurs
sénateurs LR également pour eux
l'uniforme symbolise un lien
d'appartenance vous l'avez dit elle est
pas mal aussi de donner un sentiment
d'ordre et de discipline adapté je cite
à l'apprentissage du savoir et quand on
lit l'exposé des motifs vous le voyez à
l'écran en remarque que c'était
également cette référence au sport
l'uniforme portée par les sportifs fait
rêver les joueurs comme les supporters
porter le maillot de son équipe signifie
faire corps avec le groupe un dernier
mot pour dire que cette proposition de
loi mentionne le fait que ce port d'un
uniforme ce sera arrêté en mai 68 et
qu'il faudrait donc revenir voilà
peut-être un univers voilà imaginaire
près mai 68 merci Quentin calmé pour
toutes ces explications
j'aurais mis Girard je reviendrai vous
sur cette question de laïcité est-ce que
effectivement une tenue scolaire serait
pas finalement un outil pour faciliter
la vie des proviseurs ou des enseignants
qui sont parfois effectivement
confrontés à est-ce que ça c'est un
vêtement religieux ou pas est-ce qu'on
l'autorise ou pas à rentrer dans le dans
la cour de l'école alors nous ce qu'on
pense au snack et on est un syndicat qui
avait soutenu en son temps la loi de
2004 sur le la question des signes
ostensible c'est qui c'est qu'il faut
appliquer et faire appliquer la loi de
2004 qu'une très bonne noire qui a
d'ailleurs quand même j'allais dire
beaucoup aidé à calmer et à faire
disparaître un certain nombre de choses
qui préalablement étaient étaient assez
difficiles à gérer au local et là ce
qu'on est en train de voir on pense pas
que ce soit l'uniforme la solution je
vous le dis tout de suite mais ce qu'on
est en train de voir effectivement c'est
ce retour du c'est à chaque
établissement de décider comment et
enfin pour le coup la circulaire
ministérielle elle est très très
compliquée là-dessus c'est à dire que le
chef d'établissement c'est limite il
doit faire un interrogatoire de l'élève
pour savoir si dans sa conscience il est
en train de porter le vêtement pour une
raison religieuse ou pas ça les chefs
d'établissement n'en veulent pas très
clairement parce que enfin on va quand
même se le rappeler
déléguer ça à l'échelon local c'est
faire prendre tous les risques à
l'échelon local aussi enfin je veux pas
revenir sur Samuel Paty mais c'est quand
même ça ce genre de choses c'est-à-dire
que nous on n'a pas de normes au dessus
où on est sûr qu'on va être soutenu très
clairement et donc elle arrivait s'il y
a des parents ou des gens autour des
parents qui sont dans des démarches
effectivement problématiques et ben
c'est sur nous que ça va tomber alors
retour d'expérience là aussi autour de
de terrain des des professeurs est-ce
que effectivement parce que là on donne
des chiffres
ose du nombre d'atteintes à la laïcité
est-ce que vous vous le ressentez est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup de retours
compliquée de comparer ces chiffres
parce que vous voulez donner pas
forcément avant donc on sait pas
exactement si ça veut dire que c'est
beaucoup si c'est peu on sait aussi que
forcément tous ne remonte pas toujours
très clairement pareil comparé septembre
et octobre c'est pas toujours très
pertinent parce que les élèves sont
souvent plus calme en septembre qu'en
octobre donc c'est pas certain que ce
soit massif et ce qu'il y a des abeilles
à qui traînent par ci par là oui oui il
y en a est-ce que c'est un phénomène
national j'allais dire vraiment très
important a priori non maintenant nous
on pense que ça aurait été plus simple
de dire bah à un moment voir on est dans
une période voilà ce vêtement là il a
très clairement une connotation
religieuse loi de 2004 point barre fini
voilà donc on s'arrête donc c'est clair
il est interdit et donc il rentre plus
dans la cour est-ce que vous faites ce
lien entre
finalement l'uniforme ou la tenue
scolaire et le respect de la laïcité
alors moi ce qui est intéressant c'est
que dans les pays où il y a une
tradition d'uniforme portée à l'école
les signes religieux peuvent être tout à
fait autorisés c'est le cas en
Angleterre où on voit des jeunes filles
qui peuvent
conception on va dire
audacieuse ou exigeante en France voilà
on va dire française uniquement très
très construit avec une loi en 1905
voilà la journée de la laïcité vendredi
et puis un texte de 2004 mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que en fait les élèves
si il y a un uniforme peuvent tout à
fait trouver le moyen de montrer par des
signes des bijoux il faut faire enfin
les adolescents on peut leur faire
confiance pour avoir le sens de la
provocation ludiforme n'empêche pas cela
l'uniforme et s'il y a des études
là-dessus je vous en empêche
pasviseur ça va me simplifier la vie ici
si j'ai un uniforme pour dire simplement
bah là vous avez l'uniforme il y a pas
de il y a pas d'abeille en dessous quoi
ça dépend vous êtes proviseur de quel
établissement et avec quel élève aussi
je suis pas certain dans certains cas ça
vous la complique pas bon en fait alors
est-ce que ça fera des provocations par
rapport à l'uniforme d'uniforme on peut
se couvrir la tête alors qu'on porte un
uniforme vraiment parce que dans ces
histoires de laïcité il y a des
provocations d'ordre religieuses il y a
aussi une contestation de l'ordre
scolaire qui peut passer par des
références aux vidéos sur Tik Tok il y a
une part de provoque évidemment on fait
on peut faire le trigger Guillaume
rapide la première c'est que c'est
intéressant parce que ça montre vous
savez qu'il y a je crois 7 députés de
renaissance qui souhaitent effectivement
travailler à une proposition de loi
là-dessus personne n'est d'accord dans
le groupe et ça fait ressortir les
divisions entre ceux qui viennent de
leur Droite et de la gauche au sein du
groupe donc là on est dans la majorité
macronie on est d'accord du gouvernement
et de la majorité en coulisses comme on
dit il concept que le ministre de
l'éducation n'est pas clair du tout sur
cette question là et qu'effectivement
c'est un caillou comme disait Quentin
dans la chaussure du gouvernement parce
qu'on sait qu'il a été critiqué par une
partie de l'opposition de droite et
d'extrême droite comme je cite un
ministre communautaire et que c'est
extrêmement sensible sur cette question
là et après j'irai ça plus à titre
personnel vous disiez on n'a pas la
tradition effectivement de de l'uniforme
en France mais c'est vrai que ce qu'on
peut reconnaître c'est que la France
fait peut-être face à des défis qui
n'étaient pas ceux d'il y a 50 ans
également et que la situation a
peut-être évolué sur cette question là
là où au-delà de au lendemain de 68 on
cherchait ce qui est vrai à avoir une
tenue qui était peut-être plus
confortable j'imagine qu'aujourd'hui
vous en tant qu'enseignant vous faites
face à des défis qui font différents des
enseignants toujours détenu très
confortables aujourd'hui mais est-ce que
les défis alors aujourd'hui ils sont pas
très différents
c'est quand même majoritairement pas les
vêtements c'est c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment faire court et transmettre les
connaissances c'est vraiment ça le défi
principal des collègues aujourd'hui
justement moi je crois qu'on est
toujours dans l'eau tiède vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure la difficulté des
chefs d'établissement c'est vous l'avez
pour bien dit tout à l'heure aussi c'est
de dire ils ont autre chose à faire et
actuellement on parle toujours il y a un
mot qui revient toujours il faut pas se
stigmatiser des quartiers des villes etc
s'il y avait une loi qui ne doit pour
tous les défis ont changé la société a
changé il y a un risque communautaire en
France qui existe moi sur Besançon gris
il n'existe pas mais dans d'autres
villes de France il existe un moment
donné la loi elle sera en fonction elle
sera la loi pour tout le monde donc on
simplifiera les choses et on sera pas à
se poser des questions se poser des
questions par rapport à ça si on prend
l'exemple de ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a plus de
tenue vestimentaire qui était précise
regardez le to hubo qu'il y a et ça fait
l'objet d'une polémique et j'ai super ce
qu'il faut la cravate et je suis
persuadé que les choses sont liées entre
la tenue qui peut être une tenue de de
député une tenue scolaire qui les met
dans des prédispositions qui fait que
lorsqu'on est abîme une certaine manière
on se permet pas n'importe quoi non plus
donc à un moment donné je pense qu'il y
a des choses qu'il faudrait faire et
enfin le troisième point je pense que
moi je suis pour les rites il faut qu'il
y ait des rites ce sont les rites qui
nous construisent et plus un enfant et
en situation difficile puis il faut le
cadrer puis il faut le mettre dans un
dans une situation
pour choisir ils peuvent la choisir
eux-mêmes certaines façons mais c'est
pour ça que vous dès que vous partez
vous parlez d'uniforme vous tuez le ce
principe là de cette tenue scolaire on
le sent bien c'est votre droit et je
peux je peux l'entendre mais à partir du
moment où un moment donné il y a des
rites vous parliez du drapeau c'est le
drapeau ça peut être on va peut-être pas
faire monter drapeau mais on pourrait
très bien s'imaginer tous les lundi
matin le chef d'établissement dans la
cour il fait une petite leçon pas
d'instruction civique mais pendant 5
minutes
ce qui s'est passé ce week-end qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire qui abandonné des
moments qui fait que les gens va se
retrouvent qui fasse équipe que la
France face un peu plus nation et qu'on
arrive pas dans ces fracturations de
minorités on parlait du ministre c'est
une sorte de rite ça pourrait devenir un
risque républicain parmi d'autres bien
sûr comme un moment donné discuter avec
le chef établissement qui est là comme
on le drapeau je suis pas spécialement
ça nous ramène à l'armée quand même donc
vous dites ça il faut pas que ce soit
mais bon ça peut être un champ scolaire
un champ de l'école ça peut être aussi
aller dans des commémorations moi je
vois lorsqu'elle 14 juillet il y a des
jeunes qui viennent chanter la
Marseillaise il y a vous imaginez
pendant longtemps les chefs
d'établissement était malade de voir
leur professeur qui n'osaient pas faire
chanter la Marseillaise à leurs élèves
le mot patrie le mot nation c'était des
mots qui étaient des gros mots que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure au moment donné
mais pour certains vous savez dans les
étudiants scolaires dans certains on va
pas mal gamins
c'est ma génération au programme ça fait
quand même longtemps
je suis et ça fait longtemps que c'est
au programme on apprend les paroles de
la Marseillaise on apprend le
fonctionnement des institutions moi je
me demande quel serait l'effet d'une loi
sur une tenue scolaire dont la direction
c'est pour éviter les dérives
communautaires comment se sentirez les
personnes qui seraient soupçonnées
d'être dans une démarche dérive
communautaire et on voit à peu près deux
qui on parle et à qui on imposerait un
uniforme en vertu de choses peut-être
qui ne les tentent absolument pas
d'apprentissage parce que le temps
ils se comportent à l'école comme ils se
comporte dans la vie en dehors de
l'école et l'école c'est un lieu qui est
atypique et à un moment donné on a lu
être qui soit typique vous allez dans
une entreprise il y a une tenue
d'entreprise pourquoi les clans
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut avoir
un effet sur le niveau des résultats
ça peut avoir mais une fois encore nous
il s'agit pas d'être pour ou contre
l'uniforme en général je le fais encore
je l'ai dit il y a des pays qui vivaient
qui ont l'uniforme je suis pas en train
de dire le Japon fait n'importe quoi ou
euh dans la tradition française donc
c'est pas une question de tradition
c'est que une fois encore il nous semble
pas qu'elle est lancée toute la machine
pour aller faire ça avec en plus une
sorte de double de double j'allais dire
à la fois le côté c'est un rite c'est
national ça fait République et de
l'autre côté mais c'est chaque
établissement où on choisit chacun notre
tenue et je peux vous dire que nos
élèves peuvent avoir beaucoup d'idées
sur ce que peut être la tenue de leur
établissement et on aurait peut-être des
surprises sur le côté ritualisé de de
cette tenue je suis une fois encore
on est en train de s'amuser avec un
débat qui revient tous les quatre ans
alors que notre école elle est dans une
crise majeure aujourd'hui et que c'est
sur ça qu'il faudrait consensus
politique il faudrait faire corps entre
toutes les plutôt que chacun pose c'est
marqueur que la droite pose des
marqueurs la cause pose des marqueurs et
ensuite on se tape dessus à coup de
marqueur je alors j'entends cet argument
je reste sur la question des résultats
scolaires voilà est-ce que vous vous
dites oui ça peut avoir un effet donc
c'est quoi c'est votre démonstration sur
le sentiment d'appartenance à un
établissement la fierté de partenaires
donc il y aura de meilleurs résultats
scolaires c'est ça
que lorsque les élèves font attention à
leur tenue lorsqu'ils à l'icône une
certaine type de tenue il travaille
différemment que ceux qui viennent dans
une tenue qui est plus élaborée qui est
plus originale qui est plus Folco alors
après il y a des établissements
scolaires ou ça c'est l'amour ou la
cause mais donc ça veut dire comment on
va donner moi je suis super suédé que de
la manière dont on se présente à l'autre
donc on se présente à ses amis à ses
copains et ses camarades
une manière d'apprentissage
l'apprentissage aura un autre sens ça
veut dire qu'on vient pourra travailler
à l'école on vient pas pour passer un
moment à l'école alors ben on va on va
aller chercher un témoignage dans l'une
des villes où ça existe déjà on est à
province donc le port d'une tenue
scolaire a été mise en place en juin
2018 de façon à être pressée non
obligatoire dans les 6 écoles
élémentaires de la ville c'est le maire
le maire LR Olivier davinka qui a pris
cette initiative on va écouter un
témoignage parmi d'autres celui d'une
maman d'un enfant de de CE1 elle elle
est positive dans son jugement l'écoute
moi je suis pour pour les femmes déjà ça
permet de décomplexer ce les élèves sur
le plan vestimentaire et puis ça nous
rappelle voilà les socles de la
République à savoir la discipline voilà
pour moi vraiment voilà je suis vraiment
pour
cette expérience à Provins parce que là
c'est un témoignage c'est ça
les écoles c'est liberté égalité
fraternité à province ça a pas très très
bien la discipline quand même dans une
école une certaine forme de discipline
je pense que l'adhésion le fait
d'apprendre enfin ça passe par tout un
tas de deux chemins et effectivement
c'est très important de s'approprier
l'idée qu'il faut apprendre à l'école à
Provins en fait les uniformes coûtaient
assez cher ce qui est intéressant des
familles et donc
en fait il faudrait que la commune
puisse participer donc il y a des frais
si on imagine une tenue avec une veste
un pantalon tout ça ben il faut il faut
bien l'acheter en plus des autres
vêtements qu'on va peut-être continuer à
apporter à l'extérieur donc ça ça
coûterait effectivement au mairie est-ce
que c'est un budget qui serait
prioritaire dans un moment où avec en
plus de tous les problèmes dont on vient
de parler on a un problème par exemple
pour chauffer des écoles aujourd'hui
plein d'écoles sont des passoires
thermiques ça coûte très cher de refaire
les bâtiments aux normes on a trop chaud
en été
et je pense pas
avec des Blazers des écharpes et tout
bon règle tout tous les problèmes
je moi ça m'interroge cette idée de
vouloir habiller voilà tout tous les
élèves pareil mais je pense que on a des
sensibilités très personnelles et très
différentes par rapport à ces histoires
de tenues ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est
le c'est le mot liberté qui va venir en
premier c'est une atteinte à la liberté
des élèves vous le ressentez comme ça où
vous imaginez qu'il puisse le ressentir
comme tel moi j'ai pas l'impression que
être libre de choisir sa tenue
empêcherait de bien apprendre je pense
que ça fait même partie des premières
petites libertés qu'on expérimente
enfant et qui sont amus de choisir voilà
la couleur de son manteau quand on est
en maternelle quand on a une petite
fille on aime bien avoir un truc rose
bon voilà mais parfois on aime bien
avoir un truc bleu parce qu'on n'est pas
une petite fille qui aime le rose etc et
pourquoi pas et cette expression de la
liberté des enfants moi personnellement
elle me gêne pas et je ne vois pas en
quoi à l'interfère ré dans les
apprentissages le premier truc parce que
je rejoins quand même j'aurais mis
Girard sur cette question c'est de
mettre des professeurs devant les élèves
le problème numéro un de l'école
aujourd'hui c'est ça on va avoir une
école publique qui va s'effondrer parce
que on n'a pas assez d'enseignants on
n'arrive pas à en recruter suffisamment
je suis d'accord on a fait un débat là
dessus dans cette émission donc
je veux juste dire mais c'est important
et je vais vous poser la question on
passe pas à côté de je vais pas dire des
vraisembles et des autres débats qui
sont importants pour l'école en France
aujourd'hui et justement est-ce que vous
vous êtes législateur est-ce que
finalement il n'y a pas donc là je
reprends les les critiques entre
guillemets exprimées par jean-ré et
Louise toi est-ce qu'il y a pas d'autres
priorités aujourd'hui en matière d'école
les raisons bien sûr qu'il y a d'autres
priorités lorsqu'on entend le ministre
on l'entend pas d'ailleurs le ministre
pas beaucoup
de démonstration
de l'école de la République on n'entend
pas pour l'instant il paye pas vous avez
raison il y a d'autres priorités mais
bon maintenant ça va pas tout
bouleverser c'est peu de choses c'est
une petite loi qui pourrait régler bien
des problèmes faciliter la vie des
enseignants et des chefs
d'établissements c'est simplement ça
suffit qui le prouve ça ben je pense que
regarder dans les pays qui le garde ce
sont des pays où c'est plutôt l'autorité
le respect le vivre ensemble
ça fonctionne dans les écoles au
Royaume-Uni ça fonctionne pas ouh là
c'est voilà c'est pas en terme de grande
autorité etc
c'est pas une solution c'est pas une
solution miracle on va pas on va pas se
mentir alors je vous propose d'entendre
justement le ministre de l'éducation
nationale il était auditionné par la
Commission des culturel à l'Assemblée
c'était le 19 octobre dernier pape
Diagne le port de l'uniforme existe dans
certaines académies en outre-mer les
élèves
ultramarins portent un uniforme uniforme
c'est un polo de couleurs avec le sigle
de leur lycée et ils s'emporte très bien
d'ailleurs comme j'ai pu m'en assurer
auprès d'eux récemment deuxième remarque
préalable
rien interdit dans le code de
l'éducation à ce que un chef
d'établissement puisse prendre une
initiative de ce genre il n'y a pas
d'interdiction actuelle du port de
l'uniforme mais il n'y a pas de consigne
nationale je suis disposé à ce qu'un
groupe de travail si vous souhaitiez
d'aventure travailler sur cette question
se penche sur le sujet mais il faut
avancer avec des éléments tangibles il y
a une étude britannique qui indique que
la question du niveau scolaire n'est
absolument pas touché par le de
l'uniforme ça n'a aucun effet il y a des
effets qui peuvent être je vous la
fournirai si vous le souhaitez des
effets qui peuvent être discutés sur les
questions de d'appartenance et de
sentiment d'appartenance à
l'établissement bon le ministre nous dit
qu'il y a cette étude britannique il y a
pas d'effet sur le niveau scolaire donc
là ça contredit un peu ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure mais je
connaissais pas d'études par rapport à
ça
Guillaume moi j'ai l'impression qu'il
marche sur des œufs que c'est très en
même temps la réponse de papel
quand il dit
grosso modo lancer la disque voilà
lancer la discussion c'est une façon de
botter en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est
que depuis sa nomination c'est un
ministre qui a pas été très audible et
que pour l'instant sur les questions
d'éducation quand vous échangez avec ces
conseillers il y a une volonté de ne
surtout pas tomber dans des débats que
lui juge secondaire pour justement
pousser sur le devant de la scène même
si ça lui est pas très favorable parce
que pour l'instant c'est pas toujours
satisfaisant la présence des profs dans
les écoles une meilleure aide pour les
écoles travailler sur la réforme du
lycée professionnel qu'il fait aussi
avec d'autres membres du gouvernement
qui est une priorité d'Emmanuel Macron
mais on sent qu'il y a une volonté
effectivement de faire un peu service
minimum sur cette question parce que
même quand vous échangez avec lui
il vous explique et c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure qu'en réalité si
on veut assumer le débat sur l'uniforme
c'est parler du communautarisme et donc
il y a une crainte effectivement dans
une partie du gouvernement de dire si on
met ça sur la table on va retomber sur
un débat de type identité nationale a
rappelez-vous à l'époque de Nicolas
Sarkozy ou effectivement toute une
partie de la population risque de se
sentir stigmatisé c'est en tout cas
comme ça que l'appréhende notamment le
ministre il y a une partie du dossier il
nous reste à peu près 5 minutes dont on
n'a pas parlé c'est quand même la
question du harcèlement j'aurais mis
Girard est-ce que là aussi si on se dit
le harcèlement peut être lié à
un aspect vestimentaire est-ce que c'est
une façon de gommer une partie du
harcèlement où est-ce que vous dites on
est à côté de la plaque il y en aura
toujours c'est pas qu'on est à côté de
la plaque mais oui il y en aura toujours
c'est à dire si l'uniforme comporte pas
de chaussures on pourra faire du
harcèlement sur les chaussures et puis
un moment on fera des harcèlements sur
la taille sur le poids sur la couleur
des cheveux sur l'orientation sexuelle
sur le sexe sur tout ce qu'on voudra les
les élèves malheureusement ont beaucoup
de créativité aussi en matière de
harcèlement les vêtements c'est un
vecteur parmi d'autres et il peut être
redirigé donc et une fois encore là
c'est il y a un petit côté cache enfin
mettre la poussière sur le thème sous le
tapis avec l'uniforme c'est à dire que
le harcèlement ce qu'il faut régler
c'est le phénomène de harcèlement et
pourquoi des élèves harcèle d'autres
élèves c'est ça l'essentiel un petit mot
sur Provin parce que nous on a des
retours
parce que il y avait en fait il y a eu
un sondage qui avait été mené à l'époque
et où il y avait à peu près le même
pourcentage que ce que vous avez donné
tout à l'heure ça devait être 60 et
quelques pourcents effectivement
n'hésitez pas à aller amener des caméras
devant les écoles de Provins il y a très
très très très peu d'élèves qui portent
l'uniforme
la majorité des parents était pour mais
finalement le jour où il faut il faut le
mettre finalement il est pas mis cette
uniforme les parents ne le ne le mettent
pas enfin les enfants surtout parce que
c'est donc pour que ça marche faudrait
que ce soit obligatoire ou alors
peut-être que c'est pas une fois encore
priorité du siècle et eux s'occuper
aussi des questions de laïcité nous au
snack tout à fait d'accord qu'on
s'occupe des questions de laïcité de
manière plus précise que que ce que fait
le ministre actuellement mais voilà
qu'on s'occupe j'allais dire des
questions centrales de l'école sur
lesquelles on pense qu'il pourrait y
avoir un consensus politique ce serait
assez bien qu'on arrive à un consensus
politique sur l'école en fait de tout ce
qu'on lit sur le harcèlement j'ai évoqué
une étude américaine réalisée en janvier
dernier bon pas d'effet de l'uniforme et
quand on lit un des meilleurs
spécialistes français qui s'appelle Eric
de Barbieux qui est sociologue qui a
énormément écrit sur cette question les
causes du harcèlement c'est
l'appartenance genre par exemple des
garçons qui sont accusés de pas être
assez viril même petit ou des filles pas
assez féminines ça c'est un gros objet
de harcèlement ça passe pas par la tenue
ça passe par des attitudes des
présupposés des élèves et c'est ça ce
sont des discussions qu'il faut avoir
dans les classes moi je dirais ça ne
passe pas que par l'atelier mais ça peut
passer par la tenue une des grandes
propose de violence dans les
établissements c'est des problèmes pas
réglés entre adultes c'est pas moi qui
le dit mais que le climat scolaire ça se
travaille à tous les échelons des
relations dans un établissement
c'est-à-dire dans la hiérarchie les
adultes entre eux ça passe aussi par des
bons moyens pour pouvoir travailler
sereinement et ça ça permet d'installer
un bon climat scolaire on parle d'autre
chose que le détail des tenues que porte
les élèves en fait c'est un travail très
profond sur les relations entre les
personnes qui doivent s'engager c'est ça
la lutte contre le harcèlement
aujourd'hui sur cette question du
harcèlement Jacques opéra monsieur le
harcèlement c'était une priorité une
ancien quinquennat Jean-Michel Blanquer
était très axé dessus il a mis tout en
place toute une équipe il s'exécute dans
les cours d'école s'exécute partout moi
je crois beaucoup aux petits copains qui
peut abandonner déceler lorsqu'il y a
harcèlement et puis peut-être aussi agir
en ce sens là puis alors seulement qui
s'effectue par les réseaux sociaux et
qui nous échappent la tenue scolaire il
changera rien la tenue scolaire n'y
changera rien les réseaux sociaux c'est
la intérêt de travailler digérer par
rapport à cela pour on l'a bien vu sur
le Tik Tok 2000 sur d'autres 2010 pardon
sur l'ensemble de choses et ça c'est un
harcèlement qui est terrible et l'école
justement ce sont des enfants qui sont
vulnérables et il faut les protéger pour
les protéger il y a pas que la télé
scolaire mais il y a d'autres choses
aussi je l'entends j'aurais mis Girard
quand on va terminer là-dessus quand
vous voyez une partie de la classe
politique parce que là j'ai commencé moi
comme ça en disant qu'il y avait quand
même vous ne l'avez rappelé des députés
de la majorité il y a les trois
candidats à la présidente qui disait oui
à l'uniforme il y a le rassemblement
national qui l'a rajouté là dans sa
niche parlementaire ce qui sera proposé
le 12 janvier prochain vous dites quoi
c'est de la récupération politique
comment vous le vivez ça alors nous au
snack on est très indépendant de ces
questions politiques donc on porte pas
de jugement sur ce que font les partis
politiques on est un syndicat
professionnel en revanche c'est très
clair ça apparaît commun marqueur
politique ça c'est absolument indéniable
et une fois encore enfin je l'ai dit
mais je vais vraiment le redire parce
que je pense que c'est important qu'on
l'entendait que les sénateurs les dép
toute la classe politique l'entende
aujourd'hui à l'éducation nationale on a
besoin de consensus on a besoin d'aide
on est voilà c'est c'est en train de se
casser la figure c'est en train de se
casser la figure là devant nos yeux on
n'arrive pas à recruter là on a bien vu
les concours ne vont toujours pas faire
le plein cette année c'est une
catastrophe donc c'est c'est de ces
questions là qu'on aimerait que nos
députés nos sénateurs s'emparent et
qu'ils puissent s'emparer de ces
questions gauche-droite centre tout ce
qu'on veut même combat c'est-à-dire
concrètement il y a des il y a des cours
qui sont pas assurés il y a des places
qui ferment c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire aujourd'hui ils vont
passer le bac de français en juin qui
ont pas de professeur de français
aujourd'hui il y a des on a on a un
problème de recrutement de professeur de
technologie qui est monstrueux en
collège il y a des disciplines
professionnels qui sont
des raisons parce que là on voit on
personne ne viendra en dessous de 1000
euros c'est pas suffisant parce qu'à un
moment donné travailler professeur c'est
difficile parce qu'on a une population
difficile et quelque part on revient à
la tenue scolaire si à un moment donné
une application ou quelque chose ou des
gens qui seraient dans une attitude de
travailler un peu plus les élèves de
maintenant c'était pas les élèves
d'avant tout dernier mot c'est devenu
très difficile donc à partir de ce
moment-là ça peut être aussi un des
moyens mais je vous le conseille pas
suffisant merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat et à bientôt sur Public Sénat
merci Guillaume on se retrouve jeudi sur
ce plateau belle soirée à toutes et à
tous Demain noter votre rendez-vous
l'invité politique de la matinale face à
Oriane Mancini c'est Florence Portelli
la mère LR de Taverny vice-présidente de
l'Association des maires de France
est-ce que c'est association je ne sais
plus j'ai un doute AMF c'est lea
Guillaume vous pouvez pas m'aider
association je m'étais pas trompé oui il
faut avoir confiance en soi allez belle
soirée
[Musique]